welcome to the certification preparation
professional security engineer and
professional network engineer
certification
my name is magda and i'm the global lead
for the google cloud certification and
digital badges go to market team
and joining me today is corey peale
customer engineer at google cloud let's
take a look at our agenda today first
we'll review the certification benefits
then
we'll review the learning resources and
the google cloud certifications
portfolio
we'll then talk with corey about her
certification and preparation journey
and then we'll
recap with the additional resources so
let's get started
with the certification benefits
first of all cloud skills are really
critical to enabling customer success
and fueling our ecosystem
the job posting looking for cloud skills
grew over 40 percent between the first
quarter of 2019 and the first quarter of
2021
secondly over 90 percent of it leaders
expect to expand cloud services in the
next one to three years
but over 80 percent of them identified a
lack of internal skills and knowledge as
the top barriers to cloud success
and then lastly the google cloud skills
are particularly in high demand
commanding the top two paying iit
certifications in 2021 in the u.s
we also love to hear from our community
about the cloud certification program
impact
78 of our survey respondents feel more
confident in their professional future
82
can prove cloud skills competency to
recruiters
83
feel that their resume is more
attractive and then finally 85 percent
feel more confident in cloud skills
here are some of the benefits you can
enjoy by joining the certification
community and achieving your
certification
first you distinguish yourself with a
google cloud certified badge and a
certificate
you also receive exclusive google cloud
certified swag for our professional
exams
you can network and exchange ideas in
the google cloud certified community
and you also receive special recognition
at select events
let's review some of the learning
resources
and our google cloud certifications
here are some of the modalities that
really help us build skills for the
future with google cloud learning
starting with the instructor-led format
delivered by our authorized training
partners
then we also have a modality of the
on-demand training
so you can learn anytime
by the use of the on-demand content
the third piece is really the hands-on
labs and it's really all about learning
by doing
so you can practice directly with google
cloud technologies and lastly our google
cloud certified program that really
provides a framework and benchmark for
success in core job roles
our exams are proficiency and role-based
and provide you a benchmark for success
and let's take a look at the overall
portfolio of our google cloud
certifications
you'll notice we have the exams at the
professional level
as well as our associate cloud engineer
and the very recently launched cloud
digital leader this final one is for the
business audience otherwise our
associate and professional exams are all
job role-based and redicator to the
technical audience today
in our session we focus on the
professional cloud security engineer and
the professional cloud network engineer
so let's start with the review of the
readiness path for the networking and
security
network engineer role
you can notice the
resources in the learn section then some
hands-on practice resources with skill
badges
and then some additional preparation
resources you can find all of these
resources on our external training
websites
specifically reviewing the professional
cloud network engineer role let's really
have a better understanding what this
role is really about
a professional cloud network engineer
implements and manages network
architectures in google cloud
this individual may work on networking
or cloud teams with architects who
design cloud infrastructure
the cloud network engineer uses the
google cloud console and or command line
interface
and leverages experience with network
services application and container
networking
hybrid and multi-cloud connectivity
implementing vpcs and security for
established network architectures to
ensure successful cloud implementations
and you can review our exam page for
further details
on the exam page you'll also notice what
are the core domains covered by the exam
and it's all available in the
certification
exam guide that's available on the
website
likewise let's review the
preparation path for the security
engineer certification
you can notice the learning resources
trainings then in the practice section
the hands-on labs and skill badges some
of the preparation resources like sample
questions
and then finally the certification
so likewise who is the professional
security engineer
this person enables organizations to
design and implement and
secure infrastructure on google cloud
through an understanding of security
best practices and industry security
requirements this individual designs
develops and manages a secure
infrastructure leveraging google
security technologies
the cloud security professional should
be proficient in all aspects of cloud
security including managing identity and
access management defining
organizational structure and policies
using google technologies to provide
data protection configuring network
security defenses collecting and
analyzing google cloud logs managing
incident reports and demonstrating an
understanding of regulatory concerns
all of this available on our exam
website
including the detailed domains that the
security engineer exam covers
so very briefly a little bit more
information about these exams they are
two hours long multiple choice and
multiple select there are no
prerequisites however we strongly
recommend you have around three years of
industry experience including a year
at least of hands-on gcp knowledge so
with this i'm really delighted to
welcome corey hello corey
hi nagda how are you today
really good great to see you
so we would love to get your insights
expertise on the topic of the security
and network engineer certifications so
if you could start with latin letting us
know about your role and some of the
projects you are working on
yes thanks uh i'm a customer engineer
with google cloud and in this role i'm
able to work with customers to
understand their business requirements
some of the things they may want to do
to maybe transform their industry and i
work with them to understand how they
can accomplish some of those goals using
google cloud and parts of google cloud's
ecosystem
and in order to do this i need to have a
really good understanding of
what we have available in terms of
features but not just that it's really
focusing on how do you solve these
business problems with the right amount
of emphasis on performance for the right
price at the right time
and by doing this with some of my
customers and some of you may be seeing
some of them speak during google next uh
we're able to accomplish really
and impactful
accomplishments not just for the
customer but also for the users they
serve and in that way they all have a
bit of a focus on improving our overall
experience in the world today
so it's extremely rewarding
that's great to hear thank you corey
so please tell us about your
certification preparation experience
yes uh so in in my case i had several
certifications however i was focusing on
how to study
where i'm optimizing my time because
when you think about the certification
journeys and you look at the exam guides
you will see that there are certain
common recommendations across networking
and security so having a really
solid understanding of the foundational
infrastructure components that google
found will be the first thing and so we
have the ability to use instructor-led
training or on-demand training through
pluralsight or coursera so i mapped out
the courses and i also leverage the
certification paths that have been
outlined by our certification leads and
so by doing this i was able to go
through the training in terms of
on-demand training
i also
mapped out the questions that were maybe
giving me some trouble when i took the
practice exam
and this is extremely useful because the
google cloud practice exam
gives you not only the explanation
regarding each answer but it gives you
links to resources for further
information
so after doing that practice exam and
understanding if there are other areas
to focus on a bit more i was able to
really research and make sure i had a
solid understanding of those topics as
well
i also participated in community
activities where several of us are
embarking on a certification journey
together
and this helps because you're able to
ask questions and also benefit from
communicating with others
and so in this case once i felt
comfortable that i was able to answer
the questions across all of the sections
of the exam guide uh then i registered
for the exam and i was able to pass so
i'm very fortunate to
have several certifications including
the security and networking engineer
certifications
wonderful and congratulations corey
thanks
so how would you encourage someone brand
new to the security or network
engineering area to set a goal of
achieving a certification
yes i would really encourage you to
think about how this benefits your
day-to-day activities in addition to how
it may impact your company and your
growth in your organization as a whole
the
the things you're doing today in your
environment might be focused on maybe a
couple of different
patterns and a few different
architectures based on what you have in
your environment today
however in order to really be prepared
for
different types of challenges and to
really have a solid understanding of how
you can apply
these types of technologies to other
business problems it's important to have
a very detailed understanding and a
broad understanding of a lot of the
topics that are covered in the exam
uh and so i really would encourage you
to think about
achieving certification
think about planning
and i would say think of in terms of
maybe
in 12 weeks so within one quarter you
may start your studying in the beginning
of the quarter and then plan to have an
exam
taken towards the end so that way you're
able to incorporate studying for the
exam
with all the other things you're uh
probably doing at the same time and so
uh with that type of structure it's
fairly reasonable for you to be able to
uh
you know really uh have that goal
established and then also achieve the
goal and don't worry if you don't pass
the first time you have the ability to
retake the exam
so uh so again the
focus on establishing that type of
target goal and then planning your
schedule accordingly so you can meet
that timeline
thank you and thank you for all the tips
uh corey could you review some of the
synergies between security and
networking in google cloud
yes and there are a lot of synergies and
actually when you think about what the
cloud is
uh we are thinking about the the network
the resources that are networked uh and
so network security
is very important and you will find that
there are networking and security topics
on both exams so one really important uh
perspective we have at google is to
think about a zero trust model uh we've
published a white paper called beyond
corp and this is just a different way of
thinking about managing security and
network security for those who are used
to the world where you have a
demilitarized zone
and you're allowing communications
across the board as soon as someone has
permission to get into that perimeter
well with zero trust this means that
even though you may be in the same
network you do not have access so this
is again nothing no no access unless you
are
granted that by a policy
explicitly or something where you are
inheriting it so being able to apply
these types of principles across
multiple products in the security and
networking space will be really
important
also it's important to think about how
we approach open source software
security so we have a lot of different
mechanisms to plan how we are
managing development and what happens
from a development standpoint but also
when you're doing additional builds
there are many other types of approaches
and so
this is something that you want to
really think about because uh the impact
of leveraging open source
where
uh potentially this doesn't happen that
often but
it has happened where there may be a bad
actor uh and so how do you prevent that
from impacting your business so making
sure you have enough awareness of a lot
of the latest
practices
and and demonstrating competency to
really plan to protect your organization
is important
again protecting against ransomware
ransomware is a problem uh our world is
dealing with now and it's actually just
uh it's it seems to be getting worse
however uh we have tools
and products and processes to help
protect against ransomware and other
types of attacks so having this type of
knowledge lets you understand what you
may do on the networking side in terms
of how you're protecting uh from that
standpoint but then also from a security
uh and then when people think about
cyber security in general how do you
really approach this and so we have
again processes and tools and product
offerings to assist with that
one a major change in the past several
years has been the shift from just
working with data centers that are owned
by a company
to
a cloud infrastructure
and then now you actually have several
uh approaches where you're thinking
about multi-cloud and hybrid cloud so
your approach to security across all
these boundaries
and then also the way you approach it
let's say if you're maybe monetizing
some offerings or doing joint ventures
and you have a different definition of
what these boundaries actually are you
this becomes something that can be
appear to be fairly complicated however
if you are able to leverage some of the
recommendations and best practices from
google cloud you'll have an
understanding of the way to approach
this so that your company and
organization will be able to be really
flexible as different demands and
business models emerge in the future
and then really thinking about cyber
security and resilience cyber resilience
is extremely important and when you are
thinking about the uh the broad spectrum
of security and networking and how it's
addressed together
it's really
providing you with the capabilities to
address these real world problems so i
really recommend
anyone who again if you already have a
certification or maybe you're someone
who's a manager of people who are doing
more of the hands-on tasks
it's still useful to think about getting
these certifications because these
certifications focus on how do you
approach the design
to
meet a certain business need or to
address certain problems and it's not
focused on just tasks so by having a
really great understanding of how you
approach the design of security and
networking will really be very
beneficial so uh so yeah magna thanks
for
uh
asking some of these questions this is a
really important topic and i really hope
that we have a lot more of our customers
and other stakeholders consider taking
the certification exam
super helpful thank you so much corey
great insights and
thank you so much for your time
and with this we are going to wrap up
with additional resources
so if you do want to start or continue
your readiness journey in the networking
and security area
here is your spot so we are very excited
to introduce the google cloud skills
boost our new destination for google
cloud learning with over 700 labs
courses and certification preparation
resources
and to help you
build the technical skills that you and
your teams need we are opening up access
to google cloud learning for a month at
no cost so just visit g
dot co slash cloud slash free training
and thank you so much for your time
today we hope you enjoyed the session
and learn something new bye
you